our subject how
are you living
the power of god is manifested in the
beating of the heart
in the action of the lungs and in the
living currents that circulate through
the thousand different channels of the
body
we are indebted to him for every moment
of existence
and for all the comforts of life the
powers
and abilities that elevate man above the
lower creation
are the endowment of the creator he
loads us with his benefits
we are indebted to him for the food we
eat the water we drink
the clothes we wear the air we breathe
without his special providence the air
would be filled with pestilence and
poison
he is a bountiful benefactor and
preserver
the sun which shines above the earth and
glorifies
all nature the weird solemn radiance of
the moon
the glories of the firmament spangled
with brilliant stars
the showers that refresh the land and
cause vegetation to flourish
the precious things of nature in all
their varied richness
the lofty trees the shrubs and plants
the waving grain
the blue sky the green earth the changes
of day and night
the renewing seasons all speak to man
of his creator's love he has linked us
to himself
by all these tokens in heaven and in
earth
he watches over us with more tenderness
than does a mother over an afflicted
child
like as a father pitieth his children so
the lord pity of them
that fear him counsels on stewardship
page 17
paragraphs one to four god is good
and all the time i'm glad happy to see
you let me
tell my family members at baytown
laporte
that i should have been there tonight
the reason why i'm not is entirely
my fault not the pastors and i will tell
you about that when i see you tomorrow
night
but for now i want the focus to be on
the spoken
word of god i'm sorry i am not there
tonight but as someone said
i don't know how it will work but all
things work together for good
to them that love the lord and i know
you love him
how are you how was your day
good did you think of jesus during the
day
did you pray during the day there are
some friends i have i text them from
time to time and i just write and i say
pray oh pray they write back and say
thank you so much for reminding me
or i may say have you prayed today
that's probably five o'clock in the
afternoon the person says yes but only
once
i say well pray again we are to pray
without ceasing i'm glad the lord has
preserved you
wherever you are in various churches and
we thank god we can come together this
way
despite the weather and despite the
restrictions in society
to worship him our subject for this
evening how
are you living what did i say how
are you living before i proceed is there
anyone present right here you are not a
seventh-day adventist
miss your hand you're not and you're
here for the first time
all right perhaps we have some guests at
the other churches
born again and beytown report if that's
the case
thank you very much for connecting with
us and for coming to fellowship with us
and may the lord richly and ceaselessly
bless your lives before i get into the
message
remember the three favors i always ask
one
preserve reverence where you are if you
don't need your phone make sure it's
turned off so it doesn't ring
there's no disturbance in the house of
god
favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord
put your words in that man's mouth
let me tell you from the bottom of my
heart this is a serious request
when a preacher is speaking the devil
always tries to slip
at least one wrong word into his mind or
mouth
one wrong word can ruin a message or
turn someone off
and so you say to god from time to time
father
put your words in that man's mouth and
that request is based on jeremiah
chapter 1 verse 9
which says then the lord put forth his
hand and touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words
in thy mouth and i really want to speak
god's
words and favor number three what's that
think yes isaiah 118 come now
let us reason together example a lot of
people don't trust the word of god
even though without faith it's
impossible to please god
how can you not trust the word of
someone who said
let there be light and light came
and he did it by the word
how do you not trust the word every
other thing that person says
is as reliable as and god said let there
be light
and there was light this is the person
who calls upon us to put
faith in his word because in the heavens
and on earth
everything we see in nature was created
by the word of god and so doubting the
word of god
is perhaps the greatest crime we can
commit because when you doubt god's word
you virtually call him a liar and that's
what first john 5 verse 9
tells us excuse me let's pray
father in heaven thank you for your love
thank you for your patience your long
suffering
thank you to god for sending your son
christ to die for us
we thank you he because the dead jesus
could save no one
we thank you today god for sparing our
lives today
we thank you for the blood of christ
which still cleanses sins and having
said that father i now say to you
forgive us
if we've offended you cleanse us dear
god
that will be fit and clean as we worship
your holy name
put your words in my mouth dear god give
me the attitude of christ
help me to speak boldly but with
compassion for i too am a sinner
a special blessing on all those
listening who are not seventh-day
adventists they are guests
touch them their god in a very personal
way
so that they know that divinity has
moved in their lives
if anyone listening has contracted the
colonovirus heal that person
completely their god now speak to me for
your glory
and for our blessing in jesus name i
pray
amen go with me to matthew chapter 5
we'll read from verse 17 matthew 5
reading from verse 17 our subject how
are you
living it's 7 30 on the dot i'll release
you before 8 15.
and thanks again for coming matthew
chapter 5 reading from verse 17
and i'm reading from the king james
version of the bible
the bible says think not that i am come
to destroy the law
all the prophets i am not come to
destroy
but to fulfill we read those words again
concentrate we read them microscopically
there is something we are prohibited
from doing
in the passage we just read what is that
do not even think
that christ came to get rid of the law
don't even think it
because if you think it what does
thinking do
it affects what thinking affects
behavior let me say it again
thinking affects behavior the source of
behavior
is the mind that's why the bible says
out of the abundance of the heart
the mouth speaketh if you think it
and you continue to think it you will
act
on what you've been thinking jesus says
do not even
think that i have come to destroy the
law
of the prophets don't think it as a
matter of fact in matthew 24
jesus said if they say he's in the
desert or in the
the the in a chamber don't believe it
and don't go
christ said don't believe it and don't
go
if you don't believe it you will not go
think not
that i am come to destroy the law or the
prophets
i am not come to destroy but to fulfill
for verily i say unto you till heaven
and earth pass
one jot or one tittle shall in no
wise pass from the law till all be
fulfilled now
will heaven and earth pass away
will heaven and earth cease to exist let
me put it that way
no what did john say in revelation 21 1
and i saw a new heaven and a new earth
there will always be
a heaven and an earth now jesus said
till heaven and earth pass
but isaiah 66 verse 22 tells us for as
the heavens
and the earth which i shall make shall
remain
so the bible tells us the new heavens
the new earth will remain forever
jesus says it is easier for something
that remains forever to pass away
than for my law to pass away one shot
and so he says
till heaven and earth pass and that will
never happen
one jot that's when you thought an eye
or one tittle crossety shall in no wise
pass from the law till all be fulfilled
he goes on to say
whosoever therefore shall break one of
these
least commandments and shall teach men
so
and the preachers who get into pulpits
and tell people
the law of god has been done away with
i have heard that myself i won't name
the preacher a popular prosperity
preacher who said
the law has been done away with all you
have to do is love your fellow man love
god
of course god said if you love me keep
my commandments but this preacher said
the law has been done away with that is
preached from pulpits
also preached on purpose is the fact
that jesus christ
himself got rid of the law we shall look
at that tonight
we're told in verse 19 whosoever
therefore of matthew 5
whosoever therefore shall break one of
these least commandments
and shall teach men so he shall be
called the least in the kingdom of
heaven
whosoever shall do and teach them the
same shall be called great
in the kingdom of heaven for i say unto
you
what now jesus gives us a condition
in verse 20 interesting certain for i
sent you that
accept what your righteousness come on
shall exceed the righteousness of the
scribes and pharisees
he shall in no case
enter into the kingdom of heaven ye
shall he knock it
jesus says your righteousness must do
what
exceed
let's look at verse 21
christ now is about to give us an
example of righteousness that
exceeds are you following me
answer me you're following me he said in
verse 20
accept your righteousness exceeds that
of the scribes and pharisees ye shall in
no case
the question then can be how can
righteousness exceed the scribes on
pharisees
he gives us how verse 21 you have heard
what
that it was said by them of all time
thou shalt not walk
shall shall not dwa kill but i say unto
you ah
whosoever is with his brother without a
cause
he shall be guilty of what the judgment
now
jesus says you have heard that have been
said by them of all time
thou shalt not kill and whosoever shall
kill shall be in danger of the judgment
but i say unto you whosoever
is angry now this is a higher level of
righteousness
where you understand that unreasonable
anger
is in god's eyes a form of murder
now the scribes and pharisees their idea
of dude or murder was don't kill
physically
are you with me jesus says no your
righteousness must go higher than that
anger towards people is viewed by god i
mean unreasonable anger
as murder
whosoever is angry with his brother
without a cause
shall be in danger of the judgment the
council held fire
as jesus tells us this is an excessive
degree of righteousness but where does
jesus go
to get an example of righteousness that
exceeds the pharisees
he goes to the law of god
look at verse 27 of matthew 5 our
subject
how are you living what does that verse
saying you have heard come on
that it was said by them of all time
thou shalt not commit
adultery come on but i say unto you
that whosoever looketh on a woman to
lust after her
he has committed adultery with her
already in his heart
now
in our view adultery is a physical
interaction between
two people who have no right to do it
are you with me fine
jesus says the physical part is not
necessary
at all one person can be in south korea
and the other one in alaska and by this
commit adultery let's make it even more
extreme
you don't need a second person one
person alone
are you following me can commit this
crime in god's eyes and jesus is saying
that is as much a crime as if it were
done
physically this is a higher level
of righteousness which means that the
law of god controls
the thoughts uh you miss what i just
said
jesus says if he thinks it in his heart
he has committed adultery
christ is using commandment number seven
thou shalt not commit adultery clearly
then
that commandment controls the way we
think
and so jesus said accept your
righteousness
shall exceed
the righteousness of the scribes and
pharisees
ye shall in no case and he goes for
examples
and he goes right to the ten
commandments
you've heard you've read words but
here's a deeper meaning you need to
understand
if you're angry that's murder if you're
lust
that's adultery the law of god
must control the very thinking
because thinking affects behavior
if that's clear say amen let's pray
again father in heaven
as i continue to speak to your people
speak to me and
through me in jesus name i pray amen
and so we've just learned that jesus
said do not think
i have come to destroy the law of the
prophet now some people say
when christ died the law ceased
let's go to romans chapter 13 romans 13
we read from verse 8 our subject how are
you living
romans 13 reading from verse 8.
romans was written by the apostle paul
and galatians and all those most of
these epistles he wrote one quarter of
the new testament paul
he used to be a murderer but he met
christ and now he gave his life for the
very movement he used to destroy
that is what you call a change that's
conversion
matthew was a thief as a republican the
tax collector he met christ
he changed he became the writer of the
first gospel
if you will allow christ to connect with
you he will change your life
completely so that people including
yourself
will not recognize you you've changed so
much
romans 13 reading from verse 8
read with me oh no man anything
but to love one another for he that
loveth another have fulfilled the law
for this thou shalt not commit thou
shalt not kill
thou shalt not commit adultery they
shall not steal or shall not covet
and if there be any other thing
commandment is briefly comprehended in
this saying namely
thou shalt love thy neighbor as thyself
now paul is saying look
when you love people you fulfill the law
the question can be asked
what law he gives examples in verse 9
thou shalt not commit adultery they
shall not kill
they shall not steal he gives examples
from
the ten commandments now why did i take
us to that passage that book was written
about 20 years after jesus went back
to heaven and paul is still telling us
the law is the standard of behavior at
the standard for the expression of love
but there's something else we need to
understand about what paul
said let's dig into the biography of
paul
let's go to galatians 1. galatians 1
paul just said
love is the fulfilling of the law and he
tells us what law
it is clearly the ten commandments but
let's go to the background of paul
to make our point even more powerful
you have galatians chapter one now paul
is giving us some background about
himself
he tells us in verse 6 i marvel that you
so soon removed from him that called you
into the grace of christ
unto another gospel which is not another
but there'd be some that trouble you
and would pervert the gospel of christ
for though we are an
angel from heaven preach any other
gospel unto you than that which we have
preached unto you
let him be a curse as we said before so
say i now again
if any man preach any of the gospel unto
you then that ye have received
let him be accursed paul is saying if
the angel gabriel
comes down and tells you something
different
for what i am telling you turn your back
on him
now why would paul say that go to verse
11.
are you there read with me what does
that say but i
certify your breath and i'll read
carefully that the gospel which was
preached of me
is not after man for i neither receive
it of man
neither was i taught it finish the verse
but
by the revelation of jesus christ do you
understand what paul is saying let's
read the verse again but i
certify you i want you to be clear in
your mind
no doubt it's a testimony that the
gospel which was preached of me
is not after man man didn't originate it
for man didn't teach it to me but by the
revelation
what is he saying jesus christ taught
paul personally
let me say it again christ you see paul
spent three years in arabian desert
sometime in damascus then arabian desert
and he would come out of the desert to
preach
back to the desert john the baptist
would do the same thing he was in the
desert
three years in that time
jesus personally taught paul
the gospel
don't miss this who was paul's teacher
you're hesitating so you missed it who
was paul's teacher
jesus not the apostles in jerusalem
now paul went to them and told them this
is what i've been preaching
and they said this is right but he got
it from
jesus now keep this in mind
when paul talks about the gospel now
keeping this in mind
we go back to romans 13 and we read from
verse 8.
oh no man anything but to love one
another
for he that loveth another hath
fulfilled the law
for this read with me now thou shalt not
do you have romans 13
we're at verse 9 now are you there for
this thou shalt not
commit adultery thou shalt not kill thou
shalt not
steal thou shalt not thou shalt not
covet and if there be any other
commandment
it is briefly comprehended in this
saying thou shalt love thy neighbor as
thyself now read verse 10
what love worketh no ill to his neighbor
therefore love is the fulfilling of the
law which law
well paul gave us examples in verse nine
who told
paul to say that when
when he taught him personally in the
deserts of arabia
so when people say christ did away with
the law
christ taught paul to teach
that his law must be kept
no change that's 20 years after jesus
went back paul is preaching the law
go with me to hebrews 2.
we read from verse 1.
let's read from verse 3 of hebrews 2
verse 3.
you have hebrews chapter 2
how shall we escape if we neglect so
great salvation now read carefully
which at first what began to be spoken
by whom
the lord paul's how shall we escape
if we neglect so great salvation now
salvation is something
that is preached that's what the bible
tells us which at first
began to be what spoken by whom
the lord stop who's the lord jesus
preached it the gospel
now keep reading and was confirmed come
on
unto us by them that heard him now
did paul hear jesus come on
did paul hear jesus yes
not as one of the disciples but a
special revelation
in the wilderness of arabia and the
bible says
those persons who heard jesus they did
not change what jesus said
they confirmed it
so when jesus said in matthew 5 17 think
not
i am come to destroy the law or the
prophets those disciples who followed
after
they confirmed it not changed
what's our subject how are you living
in accordance with god's law or in
accordance with modern theology the
theology that says
god's law has been done away with we
have discovered
first jesus said don't even think
that i have come to destroy the law or
the prophet don't think it
we discovered that paul promoted the ten
commandments
romans 13 8-10 we discovered
that jesus himself personally taught
paul
we discovered that the disciples who
preached after christ went back
they confirmed what jesus said which
means
that paul was promoting god's law
because he was confirming
and teaching what jesus taught him
the law of god has never
never been abolished
it is still in force it is the
expression of the character of god
and it is the whole duty
of man
748 go with me to genesis chapter 2.
now before we go there let's go to james
four no james two then james four
sorry to confuse you james is the half
brother of jesus let's hear what a
brother of jesus has to say
a half-brother who grew up with jesus
christ
james chapter four chapter two sorry
reading from verse eight
then we'll go to chapter four our
subject how are you living let me pray
again
father in heaven control me speak
through me i pray as i humble myself
before you
in jesus name amen do you have james
chapter 2
from verse 8 if he fulfill the royal law
according to the scripture thou shalt
love thy neighbor as thyself
ye do well stop let me diagram what does
that mean you do well
good what does james say the brother of
jesus if you fulfill the law
if you obey you do well
well switch that around if you disobey
[Music]
so the half-brother of jesus says if you
fulfill the script fulfill the royal law
according to the scripture thou shalt
love thy neighbor as they said you do
well
but if you have respect to persons
you're convinced of the law as
transgender he commits sin
and are convinced of the law as
transgressors
now read verse 10 with me for whosoever
shall do what
keep the whole law and yet offend in one
point he is guilty of all now this is 20
years after jesus went back james is
writing
verse 11 for he that said what do not
commit adultery said also do not kill
now if thou commit no adultery yet if
thou killed thou art what
transgress of the law now read verse 12
for me
so speaking come on and so do
as they that shall be what judged by the
law of liberty
he calls it the royal law in verse 8 the
law of liberty in verse 12. now listen
to that verse again
so speaky and so do
in other words in everything in your
life live your life
as if you realize one day you will be
judged
by the law what's our subject
how are you living who is writing
the half brother of jesus listen to his
words again
he says i'll put it in modern english
you ought to so live
whatever you say whatever you do
with the consciousness that one day i
must give an account for my behavior
and my words i'll be judged by this law
and he gives us example of what law in
verse 11 for he that said do not commit
adultery he said also do not kill
james tells us live as if you are aware
that one day the standard of judgment
will be the law of god now having said
that
let's stay in james go to chapter four
subject how are you living
james chapter four reading verse 12.
and i want you to read that and see what
you notice
are you there read with me what does it
say there is
one lawgiver who is able to
and to who without the judge is another
read the first statement again what does
he say there is
one lawgiver now who is there
jesus christ speaking for his father in
that law that christ gave on sinai
the fourth commandment says remember the
sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou labor and do all thy
work but the seventh day
is the sabbath of the law of thy god in
it thou shalt not do any work
thou not thy son of my daughter thy
man's servant nor thy maidservant not a
cattle
nor thy stranger that is within thy
gates for in six days the lord made
heaven and earth
the sea and all that in them is and
rested the seventh day
wherefore the lord blessed the sabbath
day and hallowed it
this is in the law given by jesus christ
on sinai
he wasn't called jesus christ then but
it's the same person now
james tells us the half breath of jesus
there is only
one lawgiver
but there is a law that says sunday is
the sabbath
are you with me but the bible says there
how many law givers
one now the bible's lawgiver says
the seventh day is the sabbath another
law giver not in the bible
am i talking to myself another lawgiver
who is not in the bible has popularized
sunday is the sabbath and most people
follow a law giver
that's not in the bible even though the
bible says there's one law giver
then if you're observing sunday with
whom
are you obeying that's the question
i'm not condemning i'm just telling you
what the bible says now having said that
there's one lawgiver
let's go now to genesis is seven minutes
to eight
i have 22 minutes 23.
22. i won't take all of it
hopefully do you have genesis 2
as usual nobody answered the nice
preacher okay all right
okay god bless you okay let me pray
again father
this message is very serious please
continue to help me
in jesus name i pray amen verse 16
verse 17 one of the most profound
passages in all the bible
read with me and the lord god commanded
the man saying stop
what's that key word commanded
it was a command of every tree of the
garden
thou may freely eat but of the tree of
the knowledge of good and evil thou
shalt not eat of it
for in the day thou eat as thereof thou
shall
surely die god gave the command and god
gave the consequence of disobedience
now go to chapter three
let's read from verse one if you're
there say amen
now the serpent was more subtle than any
beast of the field which the lord god
had made
and he said unto the woman year hath god
said he shall not eat of
every tree of the garden and the woman
said unto the serpent we may eat of the
fruit of the trees of the garden
but of the fruit of the tree which is in
the midst of the garden god hath said
he shall not eat of it neither shall he
touch it lest he die now
verse 4 and the serpent said unto the
woman
ye shall not surely die stop
in verse 17 of chapter 2 god said thou
shalt surely die in verse 4
of chapter 3 someone else said ye shall
not
surely die we have two voices of
authority
going back to eden from then until now
we still have two voices to listen to
the voice of god and any other voice
that's not god's voice is the enemy's
voice
uh you didn't get what i said let me be
more blunt if it's not god's voice
it is satan's voice even though he may
work through your boss or your spouse or
your cousin or your ex-wife
god said the seventh day is
this let's go to chapter one chapter two
of genesis
chapter two let's read from verse one
thus the heavens and the earth were
finished and all the hosts of them
and on the seventh day god ended his
work
which he had made and he rested on the
seventh day
from all his work which he had made and
god blessed the seventh day
and sanctified it because that in it
he has rested from all his work which
god created and made
we're told what day the sabbath is
even before sin entered before adam and
eve were put out
and we're told five times is the seventh
day
they're still in the garden five times
let's try to find the five times let's
go back again read from verse two and
three
you read it quietly and see if you find
the seventh they mentioned five times
don't take all night
how many times have you seen the seventh
day only three
how many times dr aaron three i say five
concentrate read microscopically
all right let's find the five read with
me
and on the that's one god ended his work
which he had made and he rested on the
that's too from all his work which he
had made and god blessed the
793 and now the word it refers to what
that's for because that in
it how many times is that five what is
the function of a pronoun
it represents a noun
five times the seventh day
and yet people are confused today which
days is heaven
it's the seventh day now this is god
another voice has said sunday is the
sabbath you have to decide
will i listen to the voice that comes
from the scriptures or the voice that
comes from secular history
our subject how are you living james the
half-brother of jesus tells us
so live so speaky and so do
as they that shall be judged by the law
of liberty
we say everything we can with our lips i
love jesus i see it all the time
i this i am that god judges us based on
how we live
that's why we're saved by faith we're
judged
by works let me see the quality of your
faith
and the only way to measure that is to
look at your work that's why james says
in james 2 25
226 as the body without the spirit
is dead you know what he's quoting from
genesis uh
2 7. and lord god for man of the dust of
the ground breathed his nostrils the
breath of life he says for us the body
without the spirit is dead
so faith is not works is there also and
the works that expresses the faith of
love
is obedience to god's law
this is about eight o'clock how are we
living
what bible defense do i have for
preaching sunday is the sabbath
the answer is none
there is one lawgiver
go to daniel 3 then i'll close
learn something else about the law giver
daniel 3
now read clearly for me verse 28
of daniel 3.
do you have verse 28 of daniel 3
you have my version read with me what
does that say
then nebuchadnezzar did what and said
what
blessed be the god of shadrach meshach
and abednego come on who hath
sent his angel and delivered his servant
come on
we trusted in him and change
the king's word let's pause
think with me brothers and sisters think
my family at a
baytown laporte and born again
that the buchanan said blessed be the
god of shadrach meshach and abednego who
have sent his angel
and delivered his servants that trusted
in him and changed the king's
word now nebuchadnezzar was the most
powerful king back then
in the world of the bible he was the
king of babylon but god is the king of
the universe
are you following me the king of the
universe changed
the word of the king of babylon the most
powerful king on the earth he changed
his word now
in daniel go to daniel 7 25.
no no let's go to daniel 2 21.
then we go to uh 7 25 daniel 2 21
this is the vision where in the bacon as
it sees an image of gold and silver and
brass and iron
feet of iron and clay do you have daniel
2 21
read that first from what does that say
and he changes come on
the times and the season who is that god
it is god who changes times and seasons
now we read in chapter 3 verse 28 he
changed
the king's word you see power from above
can change any decree on this earth
power on the earth cannot change decrees
in heaven are you following me
now go to daniel 7 read verse 25.
you should be able to say that from your
memory
daniel 7 25 read with me what does that
say
and he shall speak great things against
the word the most high and shall do what
wear out the and shall think to do what
change come on
he shall think
to change but the sabbath of god
has never changed and this
person in daniel 7 25 is the little horn
or the man of sin
second thessalonians 2 verse 3 or the
beast of revelation 13 same thing
an earthly power the greatest enemy of
god on earth
an instrument of the devil cannot change
the word of god because it is god who
changes the words on earth my friends
how are you living by the word of god
which no earthly power can change or by
the word of an earthly power whose word
god can change
let's live as jesus said by every
word now i may show you during the two
weeks if the lord leads me when jesus
said
man shall not live by brethren but by
every word he meant every commandment
that's what he meant by every
commandment
if jesus says man shall not live by
brethren but by every word or
commandment
then there is no power in the universe
that can change that
the lifestyle god requires of us is
expressed
in the ten commandments
we have limited minds
because of sin before sin the law wasn't
written
it was on the heart the mind after sin
it had to be written
for a fallen mind to understand now the
lord the law is
love for god love for your fellow man
you may ask but how can i love god
have no gods before me that's how you
love me
how can i love god don't worship idols
and don't make them
how else can i love you don't take my
name in vain are you following me
how else can i love you keep the seventh
day sabbath
are you with me but how can i love my
fellow man
honor your appearance how can i love my
don't kill don't steal how don't bear
you see
the four for god the six they tell us
how to express
love and god
is love are you with me that's why the
law
is an expression of the very character
of god and otherwise says the law
is a sacred as god himself
tonight i urge you the name of jesus to
review your life
how am i living
the half brother of jesus inspired by
the spirit of jesus tells us
so speaky and so do as they
they shall be judged by the law of live
as if one day god will ask you to answer
for the life you've lived
and the standard of righteousness will
be the ten commandments that
most of the world has abandoned
but jesus tells us think not say it with
me
think not that i am come to destroy the
law of the prophets
i have not come to destroy but to
fulfill
let me close by reminding you of what
god told adam
in genesis 3 17 no need to go there and
unto adam he said
because thou has hearkened unto the
voice of thy wife
which is really the voice of satan
because in that brief span she was an
agent of the devil are you with me
we're children of god but if we're not
careful in 10 seconds or five
we can be an agent of the devil and
damage someone spiritually so god said
because thou has hearkened
unto the voice of thy wife and has eaten
of the truth of which i commanded thee
saying
thou shalt not eat of it in other words
because you
disobeyed i am cursing the entire world
the very last chapter of the bible
revelation 22 verse 14
as verily as disobedience brought a
curse in genesis
blessed are they that do his
commandments that they might have a
right to the tree of life
obedience brings the blessing
disobedience to the curse
how many will say with me lord help me
to live in accordance with your law of
righteousness can i see your hand
stand with me and let us pray and again
my beloved family members
in baytown report and born again i'll
see you tomorrow night the lord willing
father in heaven we thank you for your
word we thank you for the law of life
the law of
love because love cannot be abolished
to abolish the law is to abolish love
love cannot be abolished
the law cannot be abolished because the
character father of you
cannot be abolished we thank you for
simple truth
we thank you for the spirit that helps
us to understand and if there's someone
who listen to this message that god who
is still following error
touch the person's heart i pray and help
that person to understand there is
one law giver and that law ever said the
seventh day
is the sabbath of the lord thy god take
us safely home
protect us bring us back tomorrow night
we pray in jesus name let god's people
say
amen and amen
you